Is this question of scientific literacy
in the United States is in fact one of
our greatest challenges.
What we scientists would want people to
understand is a,
our science is not a challenge to their
religion because that's the tension that
we can see rising in our society.
You'll remember earlier I talked about
the fact that we build theories.
We don't build trues as I understand
religions there about truths.
That's a different thing and in fact
it's that wall that actually protects
religion from science and vice versa.
The fact that they're really about very
different things.
Stephen Jay Gould,
he used to call them non overlapping
magisterial and I think that's about
right.
Even Galileel makes this comment about
the difference two years in which these
two activities reside.
So I think that's of great importance to
us because we know from looking at
several thousand years of history that
when religion and science clash,
science generally loses.
For example,
over 2000 years ago,
there were two philosophers named
Aristotle,
aristotle,
knees,
and I'm [inaudible] who figured out that
the earth was round.
This belief was in conflict with beliefs
about the Olympian gods.
And so this scientific fact was lost
until it was rediscovered with,
because about 1800 years later.
So the religion,
there wasn't our one of our modern
religions,
but it was a religion.
And there are other examples.
The first person who had the idea that
there might be life on another planet.
It was a priest by the name of Joe,
Donald Bruno.
He paid in part for this with his life.
So science loses when a society sees
science and conflict with religion.
We could do other examples.
So that's one thing.
The other thing that we would want
people to know about is that science is
a process by which we are trying to
decrease our ignorance.
We want to know more about the universe,
we want to know it more accurately.
And the ultimate purpose of this knowing
is to increase the store house of human
knowledge,
which is ultimately to be used to
increase the quality of human life.
I think most of us who do science would
not do this if someone said you can
learn all these things,
but at the end of the day it's not for
increasing everyone's quality of life.
So I would personally want a
scientifically literate citizen to
understand that your scientists are
people that are really working on behalf
of not perhaps you,
but that would be nice.
Or maybe it's your children or your
grandchildren or your great,
great grandchildren or great,
great,
great grandchildren that in fact it's a.
it's a commitment to humanity and then I
guess the final thing that I like for
the scientifically literate
citizen to do is to be a lifelong
learner.
To not disengage because most people
disengaged from science after they leave
university because it's not relevant to
their life.
They're doing something else,
making money,
making a life.
But we're now moving into a period in
the history of our nation
where,
for example,
we have genomic science.
I like to challenge people to say,
look,
suppose you could have a daughter that
played tennis like Venus Williams and
looked like corner Kournikova and played
golf like tiger woods.
Would you choose not to give her that
opportunity?
What were the genomic science?
That may not become a theoretical
question,
so we're going to have to make clever
choices as a society about the way we
apply science,
Genomic Science,
Nano Science,
you know,
I walk around normally hooked up to a
cell phone.
I,
I see you right now.
You have these plugs in your ears
listening.
A lot of us are really plugged in while
imagine that you had a genomic device,
a rather nanoscale device that you could
surgically implant in your brain that
will allow you to directly access the
web.
Would you make that decision?
Well,
you might think that would be really
convenient until you remember there are
hackers out there.
You want people hacking in your brain,
so they're really some great challenges.
Scientists really putting us into the
position of
defining,
redefining what it means to be human,
but if that's going on,
we had better have as broader discussion
as possible in our society about what it
is that we want.
This one
that happened.
If the general public disengaged.